opposes I work very hard preparing this
show I think it shows but like any elite
athletes I need a break every now and
then so I'm going to take this time to
catch up on some of my relaxing
court-mandated art therapy painting and
I'm going to respond to some calls from
Loyola posers now these have been
gathered by my crew and I have not had a
chance to listen to them until this very
moment but I'm sure they've all been
screened for profanity and this segment
will be a total success so Chuck let's
fire up the first call shall we all
right yes hello Jordan hello this is
Neal from Miami I got into a fight
recently with my dad who says you're a
conspiracy theorist and I think you're
not one and now I'm never gonna speak to
him again so how do you deal with
situations like this that will disagree
with your family members
Neal great question first of all I am
NOT a conspiracy theorist secondly are
you sure that your dad
because even just from the tenor of your
voice I feel like there's something to
miss and something that most father
should have inside is complete love and
affection and care and trust in their
child if that's something you don't get
when you're small and growing up it can
lead to some cracks in your life that
you have to spackle over with things
like fear and anger and you
wouldn't wish that on anybody because it
could turn them into a monster I'd say
baby just talk to your dad a little more
let's get back to this painting Chuck
give me another call I have this
sandwich falafel if you had this thing
it was hot whose crispy it was delicious
and I gotta say I'm worried because if
this think it makes it over to our
shores across the oceans and whatnot
this thing could take over you know like
a like a plague and and I'm sort of
worried about hot dogs and what's gonna
happen to them because I love those and
I don't want to see them go then them go
away but I can't get this taste out of
my brain so you know I love dearie
guessing it's probably a BLT next call
this is Chelsea from Cleveland and I was
just wondering what the worst state is
in our country I mean I would say
probably Canada but I'm open to your
opinion I mean California New York City
what's the worst one yeah the worst
state denial
and no it's not just a river in Sudan
all I can tell you is wake up and
understand the worst state is New York
combined with California next call it is
a Mary from Morgan Hill California Bay
Area strong and I like what is this
Russia thing like am I supposed to love
them I hate them like there I just don't
know if what we're supposed to do Jordan
oh by the way Putin
super cute like how old is he he's not
like daddy greatly younger I don't know
fangirl great Russia is a confusing
thing I think you need to think of
Russia as a weapon do they attack
America perhaps in which case Russia bad
do they support Trump Trump Trump ah you
know you might take that as a slip-up
that makes it sound like I have taken
the word paw which means father and I've
attached it said Trump which means
leader then I've connected those two
things subconsciously because there's
some hole because I I'm missing
something with my father the crack deep
inside that there's a connection that I
didn't have when I was small and so the
moments of stress where perhaps I'm
reaching I take those feelings and I
connect them to other authority figures
and they slip out they reveal something
about myself but you'll never get inside
so I think we're running out of time and
I got to go clear some space in my
bathroom to hang this guy but I think
it's coming along pretty well
[Music]